una espesa nube de polvo en el cielo
iraquí la tormenta de arena la séptima
en el último mes afecta a 18 provincias
entre ellas la capital bagdad
hace más de un mes que empezamos a
recibir pacientes y casos pero en los
últimos dos días hemos recibido más la
mayoría de los casos han sido enviados a
casa
la provincia de al-anbar ha recibido más
de 700 pacientes mientras la de
salahedín informó de más de 300 casos
vinculados a problemas respiratorios los
más afectados han sido ancianos y
personas con asma
cuando hay una tormenta de polvo empiezo
a sentir falta de aire y dificultad para
respirar
el personal médico dice estar preparado
para atender a los pacientes
muchos pacientes han acudido al hospital
67 para recibir tratamiento además de
oxígeno hay grandes cantidades de
medicamentos en el hospital está
preparado para recibir todos los casos
de asfixia y el personal sanitario y
médico está disponible para recibir
todos los casos
los vuelos del aeropuerto de la capital
fueron cancelados debido a la poca
visibilidad algunos comerciantes se
vieron obligados a cerrar sus locales
las tormentas de polvo cada vez más
frecuentes se deberían al cambio
climático y al uso inadecuado de los
recursos naturales irak es especialmente
vulnerable ya que en los últimos años se
han registrado niveles récord de
precipitaciones y temperaturas elevadas
estos factores amenazan con provocar un
desastre social y económico en este país
aún asolado por la guerra